this week's piece in natural selections
if you want to show my screen here
zachary
seeking the extraordinary just the last
three paragraphs of the piece
some extraordinary minds are well suited
to standard metrics and are discoverable
with such metrics
are you a compliant and organized enough
young person to sit still and turn in
need to copy it to work by deadline thus
you're earning yourself the freedom to
excel in all the academic places that
appealed to you
i was
i tested well and earned good grades and
was both smart and presentable and
although yes i was always itching to go
outside i also took pride in putting
together careful well-presented work
that expanded my own thinking
but
i have known hundreds perhaps thousands
but easily hundreds of extraordinary
people who were so utterly failed by
school that they never got access to the
freedom to explore and excel
english courses where dostoevsky and
sultanate center on the reading list are
reserved for the good students
everyone else has to diagram
sentences math classes where the beauty
and connections in math are on full
display are similarly reserved for the
good students
everyone else gets fed abstract
repetition and memorization of mnemonics
in both cases uninspired curricula and
pedagogy practically guarantee failure
we need universities that expand the
human mind
we are all born inquisitive observant
and curious
all too often the modern university is
where people learn to conform make
social connections and game systems but
universities should and can and must be
where we learn to hone our questions
expand our intellectual repertoire and
distinguish between good answers and bad
in order to solve the problems that we
face in the 21st century we are going to
need such universities very very soon
yes um
it's particularly poignant as somebody
who was on the other side as i talked
about earlier in this in this essay a
little bit yep
yes i was uh because i was not
good at doing schoolwork as a result of
what would be dyslexia if dyslexia was a
real thing uh yeah i got dumb tracked
right and i think
the vast majority of people who are in a
position to think about
recreating education
are those who were already on the inside
and there aren't that many of us
who are on the inside who also have real
insight into what the brains of the
people who were told they were stupid
look like
and you know this is a point that we've
made many times in many places including
in the school chapter of our of hunter
gatherers guide the 21st century lots of
places but
um
too much too many attempts to for
instance fix education be it so-called
lower ed or higher ed
take the established
tropes the established forms and just
skim the woke off the top because it's
gone bad right it started out bad it's
gone bad it's not gonna do it oh yeah
yeah that that is not going to fix
anything you're gonna you're gonna
continue to get some people like me who
were able to do well enough within the
system to then get access to all the
goodies all the educational goodies all
the actually challenging hard
you know
difficult sometimes mutually
incompatible things that then i got to
wrestle with in real time because i'd
somehow earned it from some combination
of of personality traits really and
the fact is that most
some people who are so-called bad in
school
aren't up to the challenge but we ran
into so few of those people at evergreen
a non-selective college full of people
who had you know often gotten their geds
rather than graduating high school have
been unschooled homeschooled they were
veterans you know all of these all of
this crazy diversity along with a lot of
students who were straight from k-12 you
know who who would who had been in
school since they were five and had
never left and had come straight to
college and
the number of people who yeah
weren't totally up to speed with some of
the cultural norms of academia was
pretty high
and who needed a little bit of lenience
in terms of some things like for
instance maybe copy editing or maybe oh
you've been so failed by your education
that you can't do basic math and i'm
expecting you to do
somewhat less basic math so i'm going to
need to figure out a way without this
being you know my full-time job to get
you
basic math enough um to be able to do
the more interesting stuff
that's supposed to be happening in
second grade and fourth grade and sixth
grade and eighth grade not in college
but the idea that in college if you
haven't already
gotten those skills
we can throw you away
is
is horrifying and it's not what iread
should be about no if you survive it and
you don't end up taking
their word for your capacity it does
free you from what happens when the
authority goes rogue and and
starts saying
[ __ ] because you learn to ignore it
right um which did not you know we know
from many students that that did not
happen lots of them did take the
pronouncements from these uh educational
authorities about their capacity and
were damaged by it yes um so anyway it's
it's a it's a tragedy but i i must say i
do not understand this mindset
that imagines that uh well we know what
happened to the universities they went
woke and it's like no
universities had uh an acquired
immunodeficiency and then you want to
cure the pneumonia that killed them yeah
right it's much like the mistake of many
modern doctors treating symptoms rather
than the disease right you're going to
treat the symptom and then you are going
to produce
if you succeed you will produce exactly
the university that was vulnerable to
that disease and then you'll find out
what the next version of that disease is
it's not useful that's right which is
you know you and i spent a year uh
trying to understand how we might um
build a next generation
higher ed institution
and you know
we realized this it was never about
solving the woke problem that's just
like obvious that the problem needs to
be solved but it's square one with
respect to what you build in place of
the now failed university system
necessary but so far from sufficient as
to not even really at some level be
worth
mentioning when thinking about how to
design the new thing in a weird way
i'm not even sure it's necessary because
the point is in a healthy system if you
build a healthy system woke wouldn't
stand a chance if people thought that
what they were getting in school was
valuable and it was going to empower
them to get a better job to do things
that they cared about to be more
insightful they would tell the woke to
go away and it is only because they were
getting very little out of that system
that many were open to the idea that
they were entitled to demand things
through their university from the world
rather than to become capable that
actually reminds me of a john taylor
gato quote that i happen to see on
twitter today but we've talked about him
before i'm a huge fan of his he's
written he's he's unfortunately recently
dead he was an extraordinary educator
who wrote among other books uh weapons
of mass instruction i don't know where
this quote is from and again i just got
it off twitter but he wrote he said
apparently our cultural dilemma has
nothing to do with children who don't
read very well
it lies instead in the difficulty of
finding a way to restore meaning and
purpose to modern life
so this is this is apropos what you're
talking about absolutely
um and one one more thing to riff on
before we before we sign off for the
week
one of my patrons reminded me of a
section from this book which i adore and
i'm going to read a short version from
its zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance and inquiry into values by
robert persig uh originally published
geez i forgot when um a while ago in the
past for sure in the past um i read it
in 2009. i actually know because i read
it while i was on my first study abroad
trip that i ran
um i can't remember exactly when it was
written more than 30 years ago i'm
pretty sure but i'm not honestly sure
exactly when i can't find it in this
book at the moment um
1974.
okay
so 47 years ago um something
uh
in it the
author has a sort of a
sort of a character that is a little bit
like him phaedras who was a professor
and
he
is speaking
let me find it
about
what a university is
and
here is what he has to say
the real university he said phaedras has
no specific location
it owns no property pays no salaries and
receives no material dues
the real university is a state of mind
it is that great heritage of rational
thought that has been brought down to us
through the centuries and which does not
exist at any specific location it's a
state of mind which is regenerated
throughout the centuries by a body of
people who traditionally carry the title
of professor but even that title is not
part of the real university the real
university is nothing less than the
continuing body of reason itself
in addition to this state of mind reason
there's a legal entity which is
unfortunately called by the same name
but which is quite another thing
this is a non-profit corporation a
branch of the state with a specific
address it owns property is capable of
paying salaries if receiving money and
responding to legislative pressures in
the process
but this second university the legal
corporation cannot teach does not
generate new knowledge or evaluate ideas
it is not the real university at all
it is just a church building
the setting the location at which
conditions have been made favorable for
the real church to exist and he's not
saying that dismissively but the church
of reason he's calling him
confusion continually occurs in people
who fail to see this difference he said
phaedra said and think the control of
the church buildings implies control of
the church
they see professors as employees of the
second university who should abandon
reason when told to and take orders with
no backtalk the same way employees do in
other corporations
they see the second university but fail
to see the first
and here we step out of that for just a
moment and the narrator now says i
remember reading this for the first time
and remarking about the analytical
craftsmanship displayed
he avoided splitting the university into
fields or departments and dealing with
the results of that analysis he also
avoided the traditional split into
students faculty administration
when you split it either of those ways
you get a lot of dull stuff that doesn't
really tell you much you can't get out
of the official school bulletin
that is so good and actually um i've not
read this it's certainly on my list of
books i may never get it
no
it's it's an important philosophical
tone
it's a book i i know that i would love
i've heard many extra excerpts from it
and it's uh it's important but
i would point out
that a this is in one way uh i like to
refer to the academy because it is
exactly this thing yes right it's not an
academy it's the academy and it is also
the reason that's the stand-in for his
first university yeah yeah the real
universe the real university the real
university is the academy and so the
thing is
um
you and i fled jobs
at an institution right we were forced
to we they were literally rendered
unsafe
but
we became professors in exile for
exactly this reason
exile from from the one but not the
other right from the physical building
that own or the institution that owns
property and pays salaries and things
like that but the point is it didn't
change anything about who we were right
and um
that i think is a very
important realization and i wish more
people were had run themselves through
the exercise
[Music]